c'est
[Musique]
tout autant ya six ans jusqu'où zine et
c'est sur youtube on dirait juste 7 en
manga les fleurs de l'enfant c'est quoi
mais désormais tout a changé
parcours a bien évolué
va changer ma
on avait marre bonavena ceci est de
toute beauté
ce en rêvait depuis si longtemps de
cette ville aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui et lors de certains films
faire du voyage et de se cultiver
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qui sait
s'amuser à changer pour changer
et surtout le jour
sa virilité
[Musique]
vous aimez
sur internet sans prise de tête
en à peine quelques jours il perd sa b3
sur vous remercier le métro ça vaut mais
ça roule sans aucun doute sous entend
des points car selon lequel a commencé
sur jouer c'est nul
totalement ridicule
c'est mal ça fait mal
[Musique]
recommencez qu'écarter
s'ils ne sont
mais les gens sont bloqués
à
mais cette époque là elle est
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ces fusées à changer pour changer
j'adore marée honey
la virilité
[Musique]
timmins
juste à changer
oui
le pianiste
ce thème
st
attends mais comme quoi tu dises quiz
est c'est squeeze ah ouais c'est vrai
tu as changé
[Musique]
j'ai changé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la vidéo numéro 8
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un grand merci et un grand bravo à
qingdao pour la musique n'hésitez pas à
le soutenir c'est important soins vous
abonnant à sa chaîne youtube soit en
achetant la musique soit en faisant les
deux voilà ce que vous voulez les liens
sont dans la description je vous dis à
bientôt des prochaines vidéos au revoir